what i will say about kanye is he's the
only one
on the real level that's giving me a
certain kind of respect
the only one and it doesn't matter
because he's the biggest one right he's
the only being in the whole crew
it's funny you know but he's the only
one that's paid proper respect and he's
always been that guy
and what happened was i had asked jess
blaze to flip that beat for me and just
blaze did not and i was aggravated about
it like i yelled at him about it
probably because i found it
disrespectful like i send an order and
you [ __ ] don't prioritize it
and i asked kanye to do what he did at
that day
at night
and you know history was made and it was
just because of the respect that he gave
me
is the reason why i was so successful
was the record that they first recorded
he got played on the record on the radio
as a rapper
yeah it can't you know it was good i
mean in fact that was the first moment
we when it was the first time queen had
actually cleared a sample they cleared
it for me